Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to look at 4 amazing examples
of how we are finding new ways to harness the
incredible capabilities of OpenAI’s GPT-4 AI
and its ChatGPT assistant. These are things
that were not possible at all just a couple
years before today, and are now a reality.
One, a dog got diagnosed with a tick-borne
disease, got treatment from a vet,
but unfortunately, new symptoms developed.
Upon explaining the situation and adding more
information about the blood test results for
this good boy, GPT-4 interpreted the results,
and made two potential diagnoses for the
dog. A vet was asked to perform the tests,
and hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars,
because the first diagnosis was correct.
This good boy has made an almost full recovery
since. Wow. GPT-4 and the vet may have saved
this dog’s life. What a time to be alive!
Beyond this being an incredible success story,
two things really jump out here: one, GPT-3.5,
the previous version was unable to do this, so the
recent improvement to this AI are responsible for
this amazing capability. With that, just imagine
what GPT-6 or 7 will be capable of. If you have
any ideas, let me know in the comments below. Two,
of course, it should not be thought of as a great
doctor, but perhaps a great advisor instead.
Two, everybody knows we have text to image,
and some of you Fellow Scholars know even
text to video. But get this, here is text
to app design. Yes we just write that we
wish to get an idea for the on-boarding
screen for a dog walking app, and bam,
we get something quite good immediately. And if
we wish to change it, these designs are editable,
and what’s more, just imagine how this can be
combined together with the amazing Midjourney
or other text to image AIs to populate your
app with beautiful new icons and artworks.
Three, GPT-4 is a fantastic writer, and
it can demonstrate its skills when we
ask it something that I would not expect
a machine to be able to do. Little AI,
write the most beautiful sentence. It has to
be rhythmically and phonetically beautiful.
“Ephemeral whispers of twilight
danced gracefully upon glistening
waves, serenading the eternal stars.”
My goodness. I think most of us would agree that
this sentence is indeed beautiful. But I wonder if
this one was a fluke, so I also tried it myself.
“As the sun set over the horizon, the
sky blazed with hues of crimson and gold,
painting a masterpiece of fleeting beauty.”
This is incredible. And the other two are
also amazing. Now, let’s make it a little harder.
Make sure to use the words refraction and caustic.
Interestingly, here it chose to play with the
fact that a caustic can mean bright patterns
in nature where an object concentrates light in a
beautiful manner. But, it can also mean sarcastic
and bitter. So how do you create a beautiful
sentence out of that? It wrote the following:
“The caustic words of the bitter
old man were like shards of glass,
but through the refraction of his
pain, a glimmer of hope still shone.”
Wow, this is a bittersweet sentence that I think
takes a considerable understanding of language,
and even the human condition to
write. Wow, this little AI can write.
Four, the improvement from the previous GPT-3.5 is
huge when it comes to writing computer
code. It used to write invalid code,
but the new version, what? Can that really be?
In this particular test, out of a 1000 examples,
GPT-4 had written zero invalid programs. And what
is also pretty amazing is that about 20% of the
apps from the previous version were written
in an insecure manner, but for the new one,
it is down to only 4%. Wow. Now note that this
is not a peer-reviewed experiment and thus, same
caveats apply, I put a link to it in the video
description if you would like to have a look.
But wait, if it can write secure computer
code, can it also check previously existing
projects for flaws? You bet your papers it can!
Look! It can have a look at this piece of code,
and tell us block by block what
the potential harms are. Also,
it makes a final assessment as to
what it exactly does as a whole,
and why it has big problems. Now this is a case
where we can use this AI as a shield. Loving it!
And I have been thinking about that and found that
this is an incredible value proposition. Imagine
if when reading or hearing anything from news
to reports, we could also use it as a shield to
fact check everything we hear or read, search for
sources, evaluate the sources, and mark falsehoods
with red in any article or comment. And the
incredible thing is that I would not be surprised
if that is already possible. GPT-4 has incredible
capabilities and it is all up to our ingenuity
to bring out the best from it and help humans,
and yes, doggies too. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!